survivors mothers of schribman itza
relatives and friends of those who lost
their lives certain wounds can take
decades to heal after quarter of a
century
Shravan itza is still an open wound in
Europe's conscience there are mothers
who could never lay their children to
rest displaced families who have never
returned to their homes survivors who
keep waking up in the dead of night as a
woman mother and wife I can only try to
imagine the depth of your pain my heart
goes out to you it is difficult to even
grasp the depth of this immense tragedy
today we mourn and we remember we grieve
together we reflect on our mistakes as
we ask for justice we work for
reconciliation today the entire world
realizes that we failed in our
responsibility to protect those who were
most in need of our protection the past
cannot be changed or undone but we have
a duty to remember and a duty to speak
up and act no more blood in the name of
race or religion
no more genocides never again because
racism has not disappeared from our
streets from our social media feeds and
even from political discourse days like
these remind us of the fragility of
peace they remind us how crucial it is
to support those who bridge divides to
bring communities together and heal
those who need healing in 25 years
Bosnia and Herzegovina has come a long
way in restoring trust we
in and between the countries communities
for peace to authentically flourish
Bosnia and Herzegovina now needs its
leaders to lead the way forward through
the recognition of suffering and with
mutual respect while the memory remains
the future is still to be written there
is hope in slavery Nitze and in Bosnia
and Herzegovina across the country young
people feel European
beyond ethnic divide and there is open
path that can lead Bosnia and
Herzegovina and all the Western Balkans
inside the European Union to honor the
memory is to work for a different future
for every Nitze and for Europe a
reconciled City in a reconciled country
in a united Europe